trois soirs par semaine à Paris défilent
d'étudiants se forment aux abords de
résidence universitaires c'est quelques
centaines de jeunes n'attendent pas
d'assister à un cours ou un séminaire
mais plutôt de recevoir de l'aide
alimentaire
merci beaucoup
parfois on doit se priver parfois quand
on fait par exemple
j'ai cours du matin jusqu'au soir
peut-être midi je mange pas parce que
voilà parce que si je mange dehors c'est
trop cher
depuis 2016 l'organisme Linky recueille
les surplus de restaurants au
supermarché
devoirs pas dépenser aventure pour faire
des courses c'est juste à citer des
légumes je vous donne deux natures ces
deux natures vu le contexte économique
les organismes d'aide alimentaire
prévoir répondre à une demande
importante au cours des prochains mois
en plus de faire face à certains défis
comme celui de l'approvisionnement en
nourriture
ça nous touche dans la mesure où le coup
de nos approvisionnements et plus élevé
qu'il ne l'était il y a qu'il était il y
a un an pour garnir leur tablette les
restos du cœur font des par l'humoriste
Coluche en 1985 reçoivent aussi des dons
si ça allait bien vous seriez pas là je
me doute vous inquiétez pas on sait bien
que c'est pas le gouvernement français
c'est également engagé à aider les
organismes qui luttent contre la
précarité alimentaire mais les obstacles
demeurent comme celui de continuer
d'attirer ces milliers de bénévoles qui
permettent à l'organisme d'exister
depuis la pandémie recruté et plus
compliqué c'est évident même là vous
voyez là aujourd'hui là on voit bien il
manque un bénévole ça coince tout de
suite
heureusement qu'il y a des associations
qui nous aident l'aide des organismes
offrent à Mayas un peu plus de sécurité
une fois le loyer de son appartement de
16 mètres carrés payés les ressources
restantes pour bien se nourrir sont
limitées clairement je dois choisir des
trucs que je choisis les moins chers des
trucs que j'achète pas du tout parce que
je peux pas me les permettre des choix
difficiles de plus en plus fréquents
dans un pays où de la vue même du
gouvernement la précarité alimentaire va
en augmentant
il sera fait le bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada à Paris